Star Wars has been around for decades, so
it's a sad but inevitable reality that many
of the actors who have appeared in that galaxy
far, far away are no longer with us.
Here are a few faces from the franchise you
may not have realized passed away.
Admiral Ackbar had a pretty small role in
the original Star Wars trilogy, in fact, he
only appeared briefly in Return of the Jedi.
Even still, the character's appearance made
him a firm fan favorite, as did the iconic
line that has now passed into pop culture
legend.
"It's a trap!"
"Wow, Admiral Ackbar!"
Naturally, then, fans of Star Wars mourned
the unfortunate passing of Ackbar's voice
actor, Erik Bauersfeld, who died in 2016 at
the age of 93.
Interestingly, Bauersfeld once argued that
he thought of his movie roles as a secondary
career that he had accidentally stumbled into,
as opposed to his more solid work as a radio
producer.
He once wrote:
"The voice work I did in movies was accidental.
I was working with Randy Thom on radio dramas
at his technical quarters at Lucasfilm.
One day Ben Burtt, sound designer for Star
Wars, came by and asked if I would audition
for a voice in the movie."
Bauersfeld also voiced Bib Fortuna, one of
Jabba the Hutt's associates, and he returned
to the role of Admiral Ackbar in The Force
Awakens, which released just months before
he passed away.
As he dies in the opening hour of the film,
Uncle Owen can be considered a pretty minor
Star Wars character in the grand scheme of
things, but his death is the primary call
to arms that sets Luke Skywalker off on his
hero's journey.
So in a weird way, Owen is actually one of
the movie's most important characters, making
actor Phil Brown one of the story's pivotal
players.
Sadly, Brown passed away in 2006 at the age
of 89.
Even though he was well-known when Star Wars
was made, he'd faced plenty of hardships as
an actor.
In the 1950s, Brown was caught up in Senator
Joseph McCarthy's communist trials, and was
actually blacklisted because he refused to
comply with the House Un-American Activities
Committee's demands to name communists in
Hollywood.
He denied being a communist himself, but was
still forced to move to London to continue
acting.
As it happened, George Lucas was filming in
London at the same time and needed a local
actor with an American accent, so he brought
Brown on board.
Not long after, Brown was with Lucas in Tunisia,
filming A New Hope's early scenes on Tatooine.
A powerhouse English actress, Shelagh Fraser
died in 2000 at the age of 79.
She had played a small but memorable role
in A New Hope, as Luke's aunt Beru.
The character dies early on in the story,
so Fraser was unable to contribute a lot to
the film, but just like Lars, Beru's death
spurs Luke into action, driving his character
arc through much of the trilogy.
And even though her role in Star Wars is small,
some would argue that she's indirectly responsible
for Luke becoming the hero he is.
At a New York Comic-Con panel, author Meg
Cabot argued that very case, suggesting that
Aunt Beru's kindness and caring for Luke helped
him overcome the Dark Side and defeat the
Empire.
It also helped him find the compassion to
look for the good left in Darth Vader, without
whom he never would have stopped Emperor Palpatine.
So yeah, nice work, Aunt Beru.
Drewe Henley appeared in the Star Wars franchise
as Red Leader, the pilot who led Luke's squadron
in the strike against the Death Star at the
climax of A New Hope.
Sadly, he was accidentally credited as "Drewe
Hemley" at the end of the film, but hey, he
at least managed to squeeze in a post-mortem
appearance in Rogue One, thanks to the power
of archive footage.
In the first film, Red Leader actually nearly
destroys the Death Star.
He launches his torpedoes at the exhaust port,
but his aim is slightly off.
Not long after his miss, his ship is destroyed,
and the poor guy is subsequently killed.
Henley was a well-respected actor when he
was cast in A New Hope, but was forced to
retire not long after the film was released
due to his struggles with bipolar disorder.
After working through his mental illness,
he settled down to run a bed and breakfast
with his wife.
Henley died in 2016 at the age of 75.
Anakin Skywalker has been played by multiple
actors across the Star Wars franchise, but
when his deformed, weary face is revealed
in Star Wars: Return of the Jedi, that's classically
trained actor Sebastian Shaw playing the role.
He also portrayed Anakin's Force ghost at
the end of the original version of Return
of the Jedi, before being replaced by Hayden
Christensen in subsequent releases.
Shaw was mostly known as a stage actor outside
of Star Wars fandom.
He was a member of the Royal Shakespeare Company,
where he often played lead or featured roles.
He was also a Broadway veteran, and was well
known for taking on parts in daring and controversial
plays.
Lucas choosing to digitally replace Shaw with
Christensen in Return of the Jedi sparked
some controversy at the time, but Star Wars
fans will still never forget the reveal of
Darth Vader's face.
Shaw passed away in 1994 at the age of 89.
Jason Wingreen didn't actually appear in the
Star Wars films in person, but his voice brought
one of the saga's most iconic villains to
life.
Wingreen was the original voice of Boba Fett,
the intergalactic bounty hunter who tracks
down Han Solo during The Empire Strikes Back.
Wingreen was a well-known television actor
when he auditioned for Star Wars, having appeared
in a number of different shows throughout
the '60s, '70s and '80s.
He originally auditioned for the role of Yoda,
but lost out on the role and was cast as Boba
Fett instead, and only recorded four lines
for the final film.
He's not even credited, and it wasn't until
the year 2000 that the public discovered who
had voiced the villain.
Still, it's a testament to Wingreen's talent
that Boba Fett became such a massively popular
character nonetheless.
Wingreen passed away in 2016 at the age of
95.
You may never have seen Kenny Baker's face
or heard his voice in a Star Wars film, but
it's a fair bet you still know him, for most
of the movies in the franchise, he portrayed
one of sci-fi's most iconic characters: R2-D2.
R2-D2 wasn't a puppet or an animatronic like
so many other creatures in the Star Wars universe.
Instead, there was an actor inside that droid.
Baker was only 3 foot 8 inches, so he could
fit inside the chassis used for filming, and
he's the one responsible for crafting much
of R2-D2's "personality."
When Baker passed away in 2016 at the age
of 81, StarWars.com wrote:
"Whether it was the slow turn of Artoo's dome
to convey suspicion or nervous wobbles signifying
fear, Baker made a robotic being seem very
human."
While Baker played the droid in all three
original films and two prequels, he also played
an Ewok in Return of the Jedi.
Peter Cushing was a massive star when he was
cast as Grand Moff Tarkin in A New Hope.
He also brought an immediate gravitas to the
film, oozing menace and calm and somehow coming
off every bit as intimidating as Darth Vader
himself.
"Charming, to the last."
Before appearing in A New Hope, Cushing was
an icon in horror cinema.
He appeared in many of the Dracula and Frankenstein
films of the '50s and '60s, and also portrayed
Sherlock Holmes in a few movie adaptations.
After a long and illustrious career, Cushing
passed away in 1994 at the age of 81.
Despite this, however, he technically reprised
his role as Tarkin in Rogue One: A Star Wars
Story, even though the film came out over
20 years after his death.
Cushing was recreated in the film with state
of the art CGI, nearly climbing out of the
uncanny valley in the process.
Nearly.
Even though Obi-Wan Kenobi died in A New Hope,
Alec Guiness appeared in the other films of
the original trilogy, thanks to the power
of the Force.
His casting lent some credibility to the original
film, but he also infamously viewed the story
as, in his words, "fairy tale rubbish."
Guinness was a hugely famous actor when he
signed on for George Lucas' space opera.
He'd won an Oscar for The Bridge on the River
Kwai and had starred in classics such as Lawrence
of Arabia and Doctor Zhivago.
And while many of the leading actors in Star
Wars are big names now, they weren't at the
time, making Guinness by far the biggest star
in the movie in 1977.
But why did he join the project if he hated
the material?
Well, there were a couple of reasons.
First, he thought the moral of the story was
admirable enough.
Second, he wouldn't have to do any publicity
for the film.
And third, the studio offered him a massive
salary.
Of course, he ignored any fan mail he received
about Star Wars, and hated discussing his
role as Obi-Wan.
Sir Alec Guinness passed away in the year
2000 at the age of 86.
One of the most prolific actors in the Star
Wars franchise, Christopher Lee's career spans
over 250 roles over the length of his career.
Lee is absolutely one of the gods of geekdom,
and has graced several of Hollywood's most
notable franchises.
Here, he portrayed Count Dooku in two of the
prequel films, Attack of the Clones and Revenge
of the Sith.
Lee became a star due to his many appearances
in the Hammer Horror Dracula franchise, where,
funnily enough, he frequently collaborated
with another Star Wars alum: Peter Cushing.
Lee's imposing figure and commanding voice
made him perfectly suited to playing the villain,
which helped him a great deal in arguably
his biggest ever film role: playing Saruman
in The Lord of the Rings.
A man of many talents, Christopher Lee also
released a number of heavy metal albums when
he was in his 80s and 90s.
He was also knighted, served in the Second
World War as a member of the RAF and was attached
to the British Army's Long Range Desert Group,
the precursor of the modern-day SAS.
He passed away in 2015 at the age of 93.
Despite never having showed his face on-screen
in Star Wars, Peter Mayhew quickly became
one of the saga's most iconic characters.
His performance as Chewbacca helped bring
a sense of real humanity to a character where
many other actors could easily have been lost
beneath the mask.
"Laugh it up, fuzzball."
Mayhew was a hospital orderly when he auditioned
for Chewbacca, and even kept that job until
after Return of the Jedi was released.
The 7 foot 3 inch actor then essentially made
his living off the role for the rest of his
life, attending conventions as a fan favorite
star for decades.
He eventually reprised the role in 2015's
The Force Awakens.
Nearly everyone who worked with Mayhew on
the Star Wars franchise had nothing but kind
things to say about him.
After his death in April 2019, Mark Hamill
wrote on Twitter:
"He was the gentlest of giants.
A big man with an even bigger heart who never
failed to make me smile, and a loyal friend
who I loved dearly.
I'm grateful for the memories we shared and
I'm a better man for just having known him."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.